with more than 30 states seeing
increases in daily coronavirus cases
more governors are putting the brakes on
reopening at least 16 states have either
paused or rolled back their plans for
reopening at California is shutting down
bars that don't serve food in several
counties that includes Los Angeles
County and Arizona the governor ordered
the closure of bars jims movie theaters
and water parks for the next 30 days
Arizona has the highest rate of positive
tests in the country ahead of Florida
and Nevada nearly 24% of the tests there
have come back positive that's compared
to just seven percent nationally over
the last seven days according to the
World Health Organization the rate
should be at five percent over two weeks
before states decide to reopen well the
numbers are not good our dr. Jon LaPook
joins us now from Vermont to sort this
all out for us Jon LaPook listen
secretary AAR says the window was
closing to get a grip on this it sounds
so ominous what exactly does he mean
well you know in order to get things
under control you have to do two main
things and one is to find people who are
infected in their contacts and to
isolate them and the other thing is to
have everybody in America doing
everything possible to stop from
spreading it well in terms of finding
people we still are not doing enough
testing in enough places so we're not
doing a good enough job there and you
see people walking around not doing
social distancing not wearing face masks
so we're not doing enough and it's still
popping up all over the place people
still are having a hard time getting the
message about the testing why's it
testing so crucial you have to know
where the enemy is you know this is a
war and in a war what do you do you do
reconnaissance so you have to know where
the enemy is and unfortunately here a
lot of the people a lot of the people
who are infected don't have any symptoms
and they're spreading it so you're
relying on this spreading to say where
do we concentrate our efforts I mean
right now we're seeing community spread
so we're seeing it pop up the virus pop
up all over the place in but it's kind
of like whack-a-mole but imagine gale
whack-a-mole but the
is invisible in order to see where the
danger is you have to do the testing
because people don't have symptoms and
it said still that ongoing question John
to mask or not to mask you know that is
now turning such a political issue but
really it's a health issue it's
absolutely a health issue it should not
be politicized and a friend of mine had
an analogy said you know it's world war
ii say and it's the blitzkrieg and
london is being bombed at night and what
did they do they told people to black
out their windows so that the buildings
couldn't be seen well imagine that there
was one person who said yeah I'm gonna
keep the lights on in my building
well the bombs might not hit your
building but they might hit the building
next door so you're killing potentially
not only yourself but people around you
and we have to have that kind of
community type of thinking where we're
helping not just ourselves but our
neighbors this is one of those cases
where listen we pride ourselves in you
osa being number one being number one we
don't want to be number one on this what
are the other countries doing that we're
not say in South Korea in Singapore in
Taiwan they seem to they seem to have
figured this out we have not yeah it's
very discouraging I've you know I'm a
very optimistic person and I'm just
scratching my head why can't we do this
you're exactly right I'll do my little
air graphics you see in Europe the the
case is going up and down you see in
Taiwan and Singapore in South Korea and
New Zealand up and down and they're able
to control it because they really jumped
on top of this they isolated people they
did a lot of testing and isolation works
the other thing they did is you know
they they had an easier time of wearing
these masks remember in 2003 there was
the stars outbreak and so especially in
Asia people are used to it's part of the
culture to wear the masks it's not felt
to be a political statement it's a
health issue just as you say john help
us understand this who they say we might
have to go back into lockdown but isn't
it inevitable that when you come out of
lockdown there's gonna be a spike in
cases I don't think it is inevitable and
I think that's what people have to get
through their head
that it's in their benefits to their own
personal benefit to do everything you
could come out of of lockdown tomorrow
and if every single solitary person in
the United States wore a mask which has
been shown to decrease spread did social
distancing and we looked at the
building's we made the building safer we
include we improve the ventilation maybe
we put UV filters inside to kill virus
and the ducts things like that we could
start to go back and resume our economy
and resume our lives in a way that I
think is a lot safer we're seeing this
in Europe we're seeing this in other
parts of the world we should be able to
do it too it's very dramatic to see I
wish every single person could see this
video of people just speaking they say
just talking or even sort of singing or
talking loudly and you see the little
particles coming out of their mouths and
then they put a mask on a simple
washcloth even and it dramatically goes
down it makes a difference to do these
public health measures I saw that video
thank you John with fourth of July
coming up not a good idea to go to a
crowded beach thank you so much